en este vídeo vamos a aprender algunas
cositas acerca de la expansión en
fracciones parciales déjame escribirlo
por acá le voy a poner expansión
expansión expansión en fracciones
fracciones fracciones parciales
garcía les parciales también se le
conoce como descomposición en fracciones
parciales vale bueno la idea es empezar
con una expresión racional o sea una
expresión que tenga un polinomio en el
numerador y en el denominador y esa
expresión la vamos a descomponer en
algunas partes más sencillas ahora para
empezar a hacer esto de la expansión en
fracciones parciales tenemos que
asegurarnos que el numerador tenga menor
grado que el denominador pero eso no
sucede en este ejemplo de aquí entonces
lo primero que tenemos que hacer en este
caso es hacer una división larga de
polinomios para bajarle el grado el
numerador vamos a hacerlo esto nos va a
ayudar a repasar la división larga así
que eso está padre entonces lo que
tenemos que hacer es dividir entre x al
cuadrado menos 3x menos 40 menos 40 a la
expresión y aquí va el numerador x al
cuadrado menos 2 x menos 37 entonces
para hacer esta división larga lo que
teníamos que hacer es preguntarnos
cuántas veces
x al cuadrado en x al cuadrado bueno
aquí está sencillo simplemente cabe una
vez va ahora multiplicamos 1 por esta
expresión nos queda x al cuadrado menos
13 x menos 40 y entonces ahora tenemos
que restar así que déjame cambiarle los
signos esto es menos éste es más éste es
más
entonces estos se cancelan menos 2 x 3 x
s x y menos 37 40 es más 3 muy bien
entonces después de hacer esta operación
lo que podemos hacer es reescribir esta
expresión racional como 11 + x + 3 x 3 /
/ / x al cuadrado x al cuadrado menos 3
x menos 40 y aquí ya tenemos una
expresión racional donde el numerador
tiene grado más pequeño que el
denominador y bueno esto puede parecer
magia verdad porque estamos aquí
trabajando con polinomios y de repente
le bajó el grado pero realmente esto es
lo mismo que hacíamos en primaria cuando
convertimos fracciones en números mixtos
déjame hacer un ejemplo rápido para para
que veas a qué me refiero osea en
primaria nos daban una fracción del
estilo 13 medios 13 medios y lo que
nosotros hacíamos bueno ahorita ya lo
podemos hacer hasta mentalmente pero lo
que hacíamos para transformarla en un
número mixto es hacer la división de
casita 13 entre 2
vale entonces dos cabezas seis veces y
sobra uno y entonces reescribimos 13
medios 13 medios como estos 6 enteros
como 6 enteros más el residuo dividido
entre lo que estamos dividiendo 6 más un
medio digo en primaria le poníamos un 6
grandote con un medio al lado pero 6 con
un medio así es lo mismo que 6 más un
medio vale entonces ya que estamos
haciendo exactamente lo mismo hacemos la
división acá nos queda un 1 eso es lo
que queda aquí afuera es como el entero
por así decirlo y luego hay que poner el
residuo entre entre lo que estamos
dividiendo sale entre el denominador
bueno entonces ahora si el grado de el
numerador es más pequeño con eso ya
podemos empezar nuestra descomposición
en fracciones parciales y el chiste es
poner esta expresión esta de acá como
suma de expresiones más sencillas cuyos
denominadores sean factores de este
denominador vale entonces pues vamos a
encontrar los factores de este
denominador eso sería una buena forma de
empezar
hay que encontrar dos números que
multiplicados nos den nos den menos 40 y
que sumados nos den menos 3 a ver creo
que 8 y menos 5 casi menos 8 y 5
entonces según yo el denominador lo
podemos poner común x x 8 por x + 5 si
verdad 5 x menos 8 es menos 40 58 es
menos 3 entonces déjame reescribir esto
lo voy a esto lo voy a reescribir como
uno más
x + 3 x 3 dividido entre x menos 8 x 8 x
x + 5 excelente entonces ya factor
izamos el denominador vale aquí está
ahorita nada más vamos a seguir
trabajando con esta parte pero hasta el
final tenemos que acordarnos que hay un
1 aquí afuerita vale entonces déjame
copiar esta que es con la que vamos a
trabajar la voy a poner aquí al lado
entonces es x 3 dividido entre x menos 8
x menos 8 x x + 5 x + 5 y lo que yo
afirmo es que esto se puede poner en
expresiones más simples de la siguiente
forma yo digo que se puede poner como
una cierta constante a dividida entre x
y a eso le sumamos una constante ve
dividida entre x 5 x + 5 entonces eso es
lo que yo afirmo ahorita vamos a hacer
las cuentas para ver si de adeveras
podemos determinar a ive y si podemos
encontrarlos entonces listo vamos a
haber logrado expresar esto como suma de
expresiones más sencillas vale entonces
cómo lo vamos a hacer para determinar
quiénes son a hebe pues justo vamos a
intentar este pues hacer la suma de este
lado y comparar los coeficientes
numerador y denominador entonces déjame
hacer la suma voy a cambiar de color voy
a cambiar este rosa entonces para hacer
la suma de este lado necesitamos un
denominador común y parejo y para dar el
denominador común tenemos que
multiplicar estos dos ya nos queda x
menos 8 x x más cinco vale va entonces
ese es el denominador común pero ahora
está a ésta
pues hay que ajustarla porque aquí en el
denominador multiplicamos por x + 5 así
que arriba también hay que multiplicar
por x más 5 nos quedaría
a word x 5 vale y a eso tenemos que
sumar lo que corresponda a este sumando
entonces otra vez ponemos denominador
común x menos 8 por x + 5 pero ahora
multiplicamos por x menos ocho así que
también hay que hacerlo arriba nos queda
b por x menos 8 observa que estas dos
son igualitas al cancelar los x + 5 nos
queda esta al cancelar los x menos ocho
nos queda están acá vale entonces déjame
hacer ahora si la suma voy a continuar
con mis signos de igual por acá entonces
esta expresión con la que empezamos es
igual a a
por x 5
a por x 5 + b por x 8 x 8 muy bien y eso
dividido entre x 8 x 8 x x + 5 x + 5
pero observa tenemos que los
denominadores ya son iguales de la de él
con lo que empezamos y con lo que
terminamos así que para que las cosas
realmente sean iguales los numeradores
tienen que ser iguales entonces ahora lo
que vamos a hacer es igualar el
numerador entonces necesitamos o bueno
basta ver que x 3 sea igual
aa por x + 5 a por x 5 + b x x menos 8 b
por x menos 8
y a partir de aquí hay dos formas de
continuar una de enseñanza en secundaria
otra al aprender después una vez más
rápida vamos a empezar con la rapidez y
después platicamos de las demás vale
bueno de la otra entonces la forma
rápida de resolver para encontrar a ive
es poner valores de x que nos permitan
cancelar algunos coeficientes a qué me
refiero con esto por ejemplo qué sucede
si le pongo x igual a menos 5 entonces
déjame hacerlo por acá si le pongo x
igual igual a menos 5 si le pongo x
igual a menos 5 entonces esta expresión
de acá se va a cancelar porque nos va a
quedar menos cinco más cinco déjame
escribirlo con calma o sea si pongo x
igual a menos 5 me queda menos cinco
menos cinco más tres es igual
por menos 55
más ve por menos 58 menos 58 muy bien
entonces estoy aquí se va a cancelar
verdad menos 55 es cero entonces nos va
a quedar que menos 53 es decir menos dos
menos dos es igual a b b por menos 58 o
sea por menos 13 por menos 13
de esta forma dividiendo entre menos 13
tenemos que los signos menos se cancelan
y por lo tanto b es igual a 2 entre 13
entonces ahí ya tenemos el valor de b
está padre b es igual a 2 entre 13 y
podemos hacer algo similar para
determinar el valor de a ahora que
tenemos que hacer que este se cancele
entonces evaluamos en x igual a 8 nos
quedaría 11 8 más 3 11 es igual
a por 85 o sea a 13
+ b x x 8 pero x es 8 entonces esto se
cancela entonces nos queda que 11 es
igual a 13 a 0 vale entonces ahora
dividimos entre 13 y nos queda que 11
tercios 11 tercios es igual
excelente entonces ya tenemos los
valores de a&b que funcionan para que
estas dos expresiones sean iguales aquí
este a lo podemos cambiar por 11 entre
13 11 entre 13
estévez lo podemos cambiar por 2 entre
13 2 entre 13 y esto está padrísimo
porque podemos irnos para acá arriba
para acá arriba y entonces ya podemos
podemos escribir nuestra expresión
original como si nuestra expresión
original va a ser igual a aquí hay un 1
que teníamos que poner a uno más y ahora
vamos a poner estas de acá 11 sobre 13
11 sobre 13 / x 8 lo voy a poner así
podrías poner el 3 en el denominador si
no quieres una fracción sobre fracción
pero bueno yo lo voy a dejar así más 2
sobre 13 2 sobre 13 dividido entre x más
5 y listo
podemos cambiar nuestra expresión de
aquí a una expresión más simple bueno
podemos pensar si realmente estoy aquí
es una expresión más simple porque en
vez de tener un sumando ahora tenemos 3
pero lo que sí es cierto es que es una
suma de expresiones más simples en los
cuales cada uno de ellos tiene un grado
menor tanto en el numerador como en el
denominador vale y bueno te hace estar
preguntando para qué sirve esto para que
si tenemos un sumando lo convertimos en
3 a lo mejor en álgebra si por si mismo
pues nos sirve pero esta técnica ayuda
muchísimo cuando te enfrentes con
problemas en cálculo y en ecuaciones
diferenciales resulta que después va a
ser más fácil integrar cosas de este
estilo
cada uno de estos sumandos encontrarle
su anti derivada que que integrar esto
y de manera similar cuando estés
haciendo ecuaciones diferenciales va a
ser más fácil encontrar la transformada
de laplace de estas expresiones que de
esta expresión de la izquierda bueno
entonces esta es una herramienta más
para tu caja de herramientas matemáticas
espero que te sea de ayuda y bueno nos
vamos a seguir viendo en otros vídeos
porque este tema de fracciones parciales
todavía da muchas cosas y de las cuales
se pueden platicar vale bueno nos vemos
en próximos vídeos